Mr Buffett how can I make 30 billion
dollars start you on them the big thing
about it is we started building this
little snowball on top of a very long
hill so we started a very early age
enrolling the snowball down and of
course the snowball the nature of
Compounders versus it behaves like a
snowball of sticky snow and the trick is
to have a very long hill which means
either starting very young or living
very to be very old you know I would do
it exactly the same way if I were doing
it in the investment world I mean if I
were getting out of school today and I
had ten thousand dollars to invest I'd
start with the A's I would start going
right through companies and I probably
would focus on smaller companies because
I would be working with smaller sums and
there's more chance that something has
overlooked but I mean you have to buy
businesses and you or little pieces of
businesses called stocks and you have to
buy them at attractive prices and you
have to buy into good businesses and
that advice will be the same 100 years
from now in terms of investing that's
that's what it's all about and you can't
expect anybody else to do it for you
you've got to learn what you what you
know and what you don't know and within
the arena what you no you have to just
pursue it very vigorously and act on it
when you find it and you can't look
around for people to agree with you you
know you have to think for yourself I
started off investing at a really young
age how early seven
which is just completely bizarre right
but here's here's the thing I was
obsessed with money as a kid so I when I
would go and visit my grandmother all I
wanted to do was play Monopoly it was my
favorite game in the whole world and my
parents hated playing with me because I
would always win so when I would go
visit my grandmother in Milwaukee
Wisconsin she would do whatever I wanted
and I want to play Monopoly so at seven
years old the other thing she would do
that my parents wouldn't do my parents
are very mean no I'm kidding I would
want to go to McDonald's
so my grammar go you want to go to
McDonald's we'll go to McDonald's right
we could go to McDonald's twice a day
even it was amazing whoa so seven years
old I'm at McDonald's and my grandmother
says to me she leans forward she says
you know David I'm going to teach you
how to play Monopoly today for real I go
what do you mean she says well you love
to play the game of money how about I
teach you how to play money for real so
she she taught me a lesson at seven on
my seven-year-old experience
she taught me a lesson seven that by the
way all of you can teach your kids you
can teach yourself
because at seven I got it she said seven
and she's like there's three types of
people in the world and I'm going to
explain it to you right now
the person right now who's working at
the cash register has a job that job
pays minimum wage
the time I think it was like 85 cents an
hour literally that was minimum wage was
she said it's a very hard way to make a
living
and I feel for those people you should
always appreciate them because they work
so hard but it's tough to build wealth
that way she said the second type of
person is somebody like you who comes
here and eats and spends money it's
called You're called a consumer
and everybody who does that
and then the third type of person is the
person who gets Rich there's a person
who actually owns McDonald's
and she said if you own McDonald's you
can become very wealthy I'm like Grandma
how would I own McDonald's
so she said well I've got a plan because
I'm gonna teach you so we went home and
she took out the Wall Street Journal
I'm remember I'm seven but she opens up
the Wall Street Journal she's she
circles MCD for those who don't know MCD
to this day is still the stock ticker
symbol for McDonald's
she said no I'm going to teach so she
showed me the price
but that price was yesterday
so she said that was yesterday's price
now I'm going to teach you how to know
what today's price is this is before the
internet so she brings me into the
family room puts me in front of a TV
screen and teaches me how to read it a
stock ticker symbol
and she says every time you see MCD go
by call out the price that's the price
at that moment he says tomorrow I'm
going to take you down to a stock
brokerage firm and we'll buy you a share
of McDonald's and you will own this
place every time you come here now
you'll make money from yourself
every time your friends come here you'll
make money this is how people in America
get rich
and my grandmother
at 30 was poor she was didn't have a
college education sold wigs at gimbel's
department store and through investing
became a self-made millionaire over her
lifetime passed those lessons on to me
my father my sister we my family's now
been in the financial service industry
for 50 50 years hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because the
thing that saved me as an entrepreneur
was watching the stories of other
successful entrepreneurs and I learned
from their advice I learned from their
motivation and honestly I have no idea
where I would be if I didn't have those
videos to inspire me I still need them
for myself today too and I hope that
they can inspire you as well so today
let's learn how to master our money from
some of the wealthiest entrepreneurs in
the world
enjoy
rule number two is learn how money works
with Grant Cardone if I did it all over
again today the first thing I would
learn today
is the money game
I believe this is the single most
important thing your staff can learn
your Executives can learn uh your your
financial person your CEO by the way the
person your CFO your your Chief
Financial Officer they don't even know
anything about finances what they
actually actually let me change that
it's not that they don't know anything
about finances what they know is
actually one of the people holding you
back
uh
[Music]
the kpi
the return the Met we're not getting a
Roi on this investment
the return on investment is terrible
this is not a good return
you know like like you got to understand
they're counting money
they're not creating it
right so our expenses are too high
we need to reduce our expenses and we
pay sales people too much money
in our in our company number one most
important protected group in the company
is the sales team
I think we gonna overpay anybody if we
overpay anybody it is the guy and the
gal that is going out bringing in the
kill
that's right
okay so the income line man this money
thing this money game this is this is
how a financial statement Works income
expenses
net
okay
I I screwed the whole deal up
I spent more time on this line than I
did on this line how many of you know
people do this reduce the expenses
reduce the expenses reduce the expenses
reduce the expenses how low can you go
to zero
how high can you fly
see I can take this number to Infinity
I can only take this number to zero
everybody agree
so I spend today 95 percent of my time
on income in less than five percent of
my time on expenses
so you're you're your financial officer
is spending all their time on what
oh this expense and that expense and
where this went and where that went I
saw Brandon the other night we went to
dinner with Brandon and some of his
clients
so that it's very very special Elite
clients and
um we were having dinner and and Brandon
when the bill came and ran and picked up
the bill and and and he took a picture
of it I said why are you taking a
picture of it well to send this to the
to whoever collects history because once
it's an expense is history
everybody agree
now have you ever gotten rich off of
History
and that's what accountants do they
record history something that was done
where's your where's your future going
to come from
income is the future right so I spend 95
percent of my time on two things
marketing
and income
and if I spend too much big deal I'm
gonna go find this is the solution to
all my problems marketing and income
everybody agree
I'm gonna go expand Netflix Amazon Apple
Google they don't worry about their
expenses they're like how much can we
spend how many people can we hire how
big can we get how long can we bleed
and one day we'll own the world rule
number three is outwork everyone with
Mark Cuban most people do a lot of
talking and most people don't put in the
effort there's nothing you can't
accomplish in in life with the right
amount of work the challenge is you know
are you willing to to do the work and
the reality is most people aren't but
that's the opportunity right it's I mean
it's like people you know at school most
people are lazy right they just they
barely get through it and and so that
creates opportunity I tell my kids that
a if they want something they're going
to have to earn it yeah and B if they
don't work hard enough to earn it I'm
going to sell them off as medical
experiments
experience
[Laughter]
you need money okay we'll sell you off
as a medical experiment we can get you
money that way
I'll go give blood Dad I'm seven I don't
care
rule number four is get strategic with
Paul or failure business is an art form
if Da Vinci came back you'd say wow man
I think I could have done some more pink
in that picture a little more blue
they're artists this always can be done
better then you're never done it's never
perfect
it can always be improved what was your
first job what was the first like
business you started the first job you
had I went to the market bought some
strawberries and sold door-to-door it's
about nine years old
I just bottom of the retail store and
sold them
ours doing door-to-door stuff
I was like hustling that's my favorite
if anything I like the best of sales
how did you learn so
I don't know you just do it sell
newspapers you just us just I sold you
know the Easter Seals for the Christmas
stamps I used to hustle Lowe's in grade
school
it just came easy to me I don't know how
I just
so how did you make your money the word
these Kinkos yeah how do I make I was a
saver my whole life
I I'm not a very good reader
and I had a lot of problems in school
and uh I kind of figured out I'd have to
do with my savings account your children
know how to be successful in either one
of two ways and then they'd be good in
the school thing whether a doctor lawyer
or something with their education or
they better be good with their money and
I was always
uh saving my money and trying to figure
out what to do with my money so I was a
saver and you made the majority of your
fortune through Kinkos well yeah
I've made other ways of making money too
but I did that
I love it here oh I've always invested
in stocks
equities and uh real estate
I think when you start your career you
have all your money in your business
do you get a little older you have
liquid instruments like stocks and bonds
because the best way to destroy your
business is not turning money into cash
and not paying your bills
then you get a little older you have a
third year business a third
and uh
equities are liquid instruments a third
in real estate then you want to retire
it's paid off real estate
a little bit of stocks stocks and bonds
and if you want aggravation you can
still have employees
how did you how did you take Kinkos from
one story like how did you make it a
billion dollar business
uh we did when I left it was about three
billion
um
how yeah I guess you know what if people
ask you that how did you be when you're
four years old how did you get to be 20
years old and so tall you just do it
I mean it just happened every day I'd go
and I try to make it better one of the
things I've always approached my job as
things went beautifully without me but
whatever I did every day I made it
better
so if I didn't go to work things ran I
had a system where it ran without me
very well well I think for you it may
becomes a little more naturally I think
for there's a lot of people out there
that are like I'd like to explore
entrepreneurship I'd like to make a
billion dollars or I'd like to have
freedom and so I think it's more like
you know to create a your fortune you
you found that there's this copiers and
opening a bunch of stores for your
copiers is a great way to make a fortune
well I think when you go to someone's
Soul the question is do you like to do
everything yourself and you can you put
up with a vagaries of human beings do
you want to eat your alphabet soup
alphabetically I wouldn't try to get an
employee
uh
uh I was always comfortable uh with
ambiguity
go on
well businesses everything I I dealt
with in my business was an ambiguous
decision if you pay people a little bit
too much or do you pay them enough with
the marginal benefit of a little bit
more for health insurance how much
benefit do I get out of that
um
I think it goes back to microeconomics
and we don't understand you make
decisions on the margins and that's all
the executive or the owner does is make
marginal decisions and you make marginal
decisions every day if you drive in the
freeway at 65 your chance of getting a
ticket is zero if you go at 90 you're
going to get a higher probability
we make marginal decisions instinctively
every day but we don't think about it
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all of the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is make
believability weighted decisions with
Ray dalio I should explain believability
weighted decision making to you if
you're sure if you're interested okay so
ordinarily
you're the two ways of making decisions
pretty much there's the boss has control
and so autocratic autocratic I'll call
that autocratic takes in everything and
then he makes a decision
or there's Democratic pretty much one
man one vote
um but really the best decision making
is believability weighted decision
making and if you think about it first
conceptually
you would say if you're going to make a
decision of what you have medical
condition and you're going how are you
going to get that you're going to think
who are the best doctors consult the
experts right consult the experts but
this one knows more and that one knows
less and how do you do it and then you
have this triangulation and then you
make that that's kind of the idea of
believability decision making we have
ways of uh signing believability that we
all agree are fair that we each assess
each other and we get certain amount of
believability points
so now imagine that you had
believability your believability on a
subject matter maybe it's investing
maybe it's accounting whatever the
subject is that you have a certain
amount of believability weighted points
and you're together well those
believability weighted points uh when
you say okay what should I make as a
decision now I'm responsible for
something but I ask everybody else I and
I take a believability weighted vote I
can have a believability way to vote
when I have that believability way to
vote vote I really do believe that it's
going to be a better decision than I
would individually make that's
believability weighted decision making
and it's fantastic
um
when you have independent thinkers
in in order to be successful in the
markets
or as an entrepreneur
one has to be
um an independent thinker that makes
decisions better than the consensus
decisions it's fair in the markets
the consensus is built into the price
it's beta
yeah
so now
um you have to bet against the consensus
to make money
therefore you have to be an independent
thinker
the best Dynamic is to have a bunch of
independent thinkers
now you've got a bunch of independent
thinkers how are they going to have
thoughtful disagreement and get past
those disagreement how we have done that
is the key to our success rule number
six is gamify Investments with our Meat
Safety we all have to go on our own
investment journey I did when I thought
I was a genius in 2000 and I put it all
in the you know in the market picking
individual stocks and I realize oh man I
got to learn how this works and so there
are some basic investment truths and
there are some basic truths in you know
every industry for example you have
people you know they struggle to lose
weight for example in my case I
struggled to gain weight I was a really
skinny guy and you could have sat there
and told me hey ramit you need to eat
more calories and I would have said no
no no no you don't understand like I
have a fast metabolism blah blah blah
and I had to go through this journey I
had to ask friends to help me train at
the gym I had to watch other people read
a bunch of books and get trainers and
eventually I realized oh my gosh it's
actually pretty simple but to get there
I had to go like this so I actually have
a lot of compassion for
um anyone who's on their investment
Journey because this stuff is not easy
Once you really get good at it it's
quite simple and you realize oh my gosh
I only need to sort of set up 20
automated savings I need to have these
kind of basic ratios
but the rest of it's just like easy to
get there is not easy so I totally
understand that and for anyone watching
we all start at different places whether
it's on our fitness journey money
Journey spiritual journey and you know
the goal I think is to find something
that fits us is simple
and helps us lead a rich life
rule number seven is shift your thinking
with Dean graziosi people think
money doesn't solve problems or money
won't
um
make me a better person or money won't
make me happy and I think however you
want to classify money but for me I just
know this
if that's a driver for you I don't think
we should drive for money I think we
should drive to be a better version of
ourselves when money was no longer a
worry for me I dove into me and I have
been ignoring and tucking down a lot of
crap for a lot of years and I was
surface level I looked like the guy that
had it all going on my businesses were
doing good I have amazing children
company thriving I live in the right
neighborhood Drive the right have the
right friends everything looked great
but it was all masked and when money got
out of the way
I was able to find dig into me and do my
own personal development and my own
personal growth and really find the
things that I wanted to fix so I could
become a better version because I know
if I'm pointing because my son's over
there
it doesn't matter what I tell him
as a parent and if you're a parent you
know what I'm talking about I could
teach him everything I give him lessons
we do Sunday meetings I could teach them
lessons every he's going to become and
who I am not what I say and I'm going to
lead by example and I want to be a
better version of me and money's allowed
that money has not made me uh
uh evil or done bad things it's it's
allowed me to not worry about that part
so I could focus on me and
simultaneously the more I focused on me
the more I want to do take my money and
do better for other people I mean I
heard somebody say once when they said
they think money's evil they said you
haven't made enough and you haven't
given enough away yet to see that it's
not so that kind of shifted for me as
like I just wanna I wanna fine tune and
hone my skills for making more money
then I have the ability to help more
people because that's the gift I got
right
um so I think I know you asked about
money myths I think I think the the
whole thought of money is evil or it
can't help problems or we're hurting
other people by taking it I just I don't
believe in that as long as the byproduct
of you making money turns you into a
better person and allows you to help
more people and Rule Number Eight the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is stop wasting money with Jay
Shetty if you want to have more money
one way is to uncover the areas where
you may be wasting money and that's why
we're talking about 5 five common ways
we throw money away where exactly did
you miss you go money is something a lot
of us struggle with check this out in a
2019 employee survey at PWC 71 of
Millennials said their money stress had
gone up over the past year it is
stressing me out and nearly half of all
respondents said that they spend three
hours or more every week thinking about
or trying to sort out their finances and
money woes don't just affect us
individually 44 of young adults said
that the money is the number one
stressor in their relationship I mean
the borrow some money and check out
these stats according to Erin Lowry
creator of the broke Millennial Blog the
average Millennial graduated with 37 000
in student debt that's in the states and
some have much more that's enough to buy
a brand new car or put a down payment on
a house maybe you're like yeah don't
remind me Jay hey I get it lots of Us
come from tough places financially and
you might be there now growing up my
family definitely was not what you'd
call wealthy for some of us the hard
times actually helped spur us on to
success here's one of the stories that's
really inspired me it's of a young man
who at 14 was evicted with his mother
from their apartment and couldn't afford
a place to live by the time he was 16 he
was arrested multiple times though he
went on to secure a spot to play
American football at a top college in
his junior year he lost his spot and his
NFL career opportunities with it at one
point he found himself with only seven
dollars in his pocket but he kept
working and striving and today Dwayne
The Rock Johnson says that every time he
experiences a big moment of success he
reminds himself of those early struggles
when his back was up against the wall
and the only way to go was forward and
that's why he named his company seven
bucks Productions still even if you
don't have aspirations of becoming a
Mega Movie Star Financial Security is
Within Reach and a place to start stop
wasting money now a little disclaimer
first what I'm going to share with you
is for informational purposes only it is
definitely not intended as formal legal
tax investment Financial or other advice
you want to consult a qualified licensed
professional for that okay so here are
those five big areas where you can stop
wasting money and get yourself on track
financially take notes boys let's start
with a super common one that's really
simple Financial expert sus Allman says
if you're buying a coffee every day you
may be literally flushing your chance to
be a millionaire down the drain you know
because after the coffee goes through
your body okay never mind you get it
anyway Oman says that if you invested
the 100 or more per month so many of us
spend on coffee in a Roth retirement
account over 40 years with compound
interest you'd have a million dollars
what that's worth making your own coffee
right actually the entire category of
food and drink is is a big one not only
do we spend loads of money eating out
for dinner another big money waster
people often Overlook is lunch here's a
quick quiz how much do you think the
average person spends on lunch in a year
according to Visa is it a 520 B
1280 and C
2746 if you guys see you're right the
average person spends
2746 dollars per year on lunches now
check this out if instead of buying
lunch you invested that money every
month in a basic savings account over 20
years you'd have hope you're sitting
down because this is unbelievable you'd
have sixty thousand seven hundred and
sixty dollars and 41 cents I'm gonna sit
down and that's just with basic
compounding interest okay so here's
another big way we raise money buying
new now here's the thing I know for lots
of us I'll be honest myself included how
we look is important we enjoy fashion
but you can continue to have your unique
look and have favorite Brands and still
spend less money on clothing here's a
way to do that I have another friend
who's into designer Brands but would
never pay designer prices her secret is
to shop at consignment stores and now
that there are lots of these stores
online there are tons of items to choose
from and you can even shop by your
favorite Brands the other month I
complimented my friend on a sweater and
she told me she got it for 65 less than
the original price and it came brand new
with the tag still attached plus
shopping Consignment also benefits the
environment because we're recirculating
clothes instead of just making more
stuff Beyond clothing there are loads of
things we tend to buy brand new that we
really don't need to
and what I found out is that people want
to learn about money IQ which is about
financial intelligence it's about
investing how to buy stocks and how to
trade and all the other things but what
I found out is that money EQ is more
important than money IQ mining EQ is
emotional intelligence about money how
healthy you feel with money a healthy
relationship is that when you feel happy
about money your money EQ is high when
you constantly worry about money and you
you have fear on money but your money EQ
is low and the highest money IQ people
with all the mbas and all the doctor
degree they are good at investing and
they're super good with business but
these high money IQ people often lose
everything because of low money EQ even
though you build a high tower with money
IQ the foundation is shaky it's gonna
fall so money EQ is a foundation of life
for example if you get a 500 raise which
is great but can you keep the money
probably you will celebrate your race
and spend it all and then if you get a
two thousand dollar raise which is great
probably you're gonna move to a better
and bigger house and then you're gonna
probably buy a bigger car and more
expenses go up so uh even though you get
a raise you make more money your expense
is also are trying to match your income
so you have no money at the end of the
month anyway I have known many CEOs who
are making a few hundred thousand
dollars a year but still they cannot
keep any money left because their
lifestyle consumes all the money so
unless you learn about money EQ and how
the solid foundation you'll never be
able to feel peace with money and you'll
never be able to achieve true Financial
Independence because you made it this
far in a video I want to celebrate you
most people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
if you want to learn about wealth and
success from Les Brown check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there whatever you do you want to be
excited about it you want to have the
kind of excitement that is so contagious
that people want to be around you
because whatever you're doing whatever
you talk to people about this particular
idea that you have